the dollar is smiling
not literally
but its value has reached its highest
point since the early 2000s
the increase fits into a theory known as
the dollar smile it says the dollar
typically gets stronger when the us
economy is healthy like when it saw a
period of economic growth in 2014 or
when the global economy faces unexpected
shocks like we're seeing in 2022 but it
loses value when the us economy is on a
downward trend compared to the rest of
the world like in 2008 during the great
recession that's how the dollar smiles
the dollar is reaching multi-decade
highs and that's because we have the fed
that's in the middle of hiking rates we
also have people that are very worried
about the state of economy i mean
normally this kind of increase comes
like over time over two three years so
this is an unexpected surge higher while
a strong dollar might seem like
something to be happy about its impact
across the world can be more complicated
here's how the dollar starts to smile
and the unexpected consequences it can
have for the global economy
[Music]
let's look back at that smile one of the
main reasons the dollar remains
attractive to investors at both ends of
the economic spectrum is because it is a
dominant global reserve currency which
means every country keeps a certain
amount of us dollars in their central
banks for foreign economies the wide use
of the dollar allows borrowers to have
access to a broad pool of lenders and
investors
according to the international monetary
fund nearly 7 trillion u.s dollars are
held by 149 countries
investors like the dollar because it's
stable they know that you have a country
where there's a central bank that has
stepped in to shore up markets and
intervenes in the economy at whatever
cost to make sure it doesn't crash
because so many countries rely on the
dollar for trade and various
transactions that means there's always
demand for it which makes it more
valuable but that demand fluctuates and
depends largely on the state of the u.s
economy when the economy is healthy
investors bet on economic growth that
will lead to eventual interest rate
increases the theory dubs this end greed
mode if you're buying currencies
you want to hold the one that's going to
give you a higher rate of return that's
linked to your central bank's rate on
the other end of the smile when the
economy is struggling investors can flee
to the dollar as a more secure asset
that's fear mode the end we're at now
the dollar's benefited from basically a
confluence of events volatile financial
markets fears around growth in the
global economy supply chain issues
stemming from the fact that china is
still dealing with covid and we have a
war in europe that's spurring an energy
crisis there and we have global
inflation so all that combined has
people basically jumping into the u.s
dollar as a haven a haven is an asset
that can retain or even increase its
value during an economic downturn
the dollar strength is determined by
measuring it against other global
currencies when it gets stronger other
currencies grow weaker by comparison
in july the dollar and euro reached
parity for the first time in 20 years
and as the value of other currencies
fall the impact of the strong dollar
ripples through the global economy
the dollar is the main currency used in
global trade
that means that things like food and
energy are usually priced in dollars
when they're bought and sold among
certain countries even if they aren't
buying from the us
so basically their currencies weakened
which makes everything more expensive
for them which means price increases
which is inflation so you're basically
there's this concept that a stronger
dollar exports inflation to emerging
market countries but a strong dollar can
actually have the opposite effect for
americans by helping bring prices down
strong dollar benefits you because it
makes importing goods and services
cheaper people like that it makes
traveling abroad for americans cheaper
that's also a good thing
but as imports get cheaper for the u.s
exports get more expensive for other
countries u.s products become less
affordable and therefore less attractive
to consumers and businesses abroad that
means that u.s companies that make a
significant portion of their profits
overseas can see a decline in sales
companies have already taken a hit this
year microsoft salesforce and coca-cola
are just a few that have pointed out the
negative impact of the strong dollar on
their financial results
here's microsoft's chief marketing
officer after the company filed an 8k
which is a form that reports unexpected
changes to shareholders say you know if
you if you saw the 8k today it was
purely uh it was purely
for currency
strength continued strength of the
dollar
essentially is what we talked about in
that filing about 40 of s p 500
companies revenue comes from outside the
u.s and a decline in sales and future
earnings tends to make stocks fall
but these lower earnings and reduced
import costs can also help curb
inflation by bringing prices down and
forcing companies to slow spending
you're cooling things down when you have
a stronger currency very indirectly so
some analysts will say it's almost the
equivalent of a rate hike so it's kind
of tricky it's it's good but when it
gets too strong it can start being
damaging
experts expect the dollar to stabilize
later this year but it's unclear when
that might be
what you would need for the dollar to
stabilize is inflation data to cool you
would need geopolitical uncertainty to
fade and you need a greater belief that
the global economy is back on track and
that growth is going to return and that
financial markets are going to calm down
when the global economy starts to settle
the dollar will likely stop smiling